hypothesis testing is is the sort of
next simplest statistical decision
problem so here we observe data coming
from some distribution P theta and now
we're trying to distinguish between two
mutually exclusive assertions about what
theta is so the first is the null
hypothesis so typically that's asserting
that you have some kind of effect that
maybe we're hoping to find or possibly
even expecting to find is not present
and the alternative hypothesis would be
the opposite so the most common would be
that the null is that theta is equal to
theta 0 for some fixed a20 versus the
opposite or the theta say is less than
or equal to theta 0 versus the opposite
but more generally we could just say
that theta is in some is in some subset
of the parameter space versus it's in
some other subset of the parameter space
formerly that's all that's going on so
then we observe the data and we have to
make some kind of binary decision that
we either reject the null hypothesis we
say that the null hypothesis wasn't
really true actually the alternative or
sometimes we say accept the null
hypothesis we try not to say it in mixed
company because it gives the wrong
impression I think fail to reject the
null hypothesis is is a better and more
accurate description of how we should
really interpret what happens especially
in the case where let's say we're
testing the null hypothesis that theta
equals theta 0 it would it would hardly
ever be reasonable to sort of claim that
this isn't exactly true so let's just
say fail to reject the null hypothesis
would be the alternative and just like
here in some sense the alternative looks
like it sort of has an advantage over
the null this is just making an
extremely strong claim we set up the
problem sort of asymmetrically to
reflect that usual situation our goal is
basically going to be that we want to
find a good trade-off between two
possible types of error that we could
make so the first type we call a type 1
error it's like a false false positive
so the null hypothesis is actually true
but we reject it anyway false rejection
and that a type 2 error is that the null
hypothesis is false but we so we could
have rejected it but we missed up on an
opportunity to reject it these are
terrible names for the two types of
errors I apologize for that type 1 there
I think that the best way to remember it
is type 1 error rate is the one that we
care more about it's the one that we try
to control it type 1 error rate is the
first priority so though you want a
mnemonic ok so but we have an asymmetric
set up just what I said
so the type 1 error is so so far
everything looks very symmetric but now
we're going to require the type 1 error
rate to be controlled in two
pre-specified what we call significance
level usually we so we take some number
alpha typical choice would be 5 percent
10 percent 1 percent and we require that
for any parameter coming from the null
hypothesis the probability the rejection
probability must be less than alpha no
greater than alpha so this is sort of
this is the requirement for the test
even to be valid at all and then do we
have to control that and then subject to
that constraint we try to have to make a
good test we try to also make the type 2
errors be relatively infrequent yes so
what point does some notion of trying to
make Li go away from just errors you
have something to make them kind of
commensurate in some sense and put a
cost in some uniform currency okay so I
think okay so so maybe you could say
that there's some there's some cost to
making a type 1 error and some cost to
making a type 2 error and that's that's
the way that we should look at it I I
think I think
you can certainly look at it that way so
yeah I'm sort of blanking on on a
mounting a grand philosophical defense
of this specific way of doing things
doesn't mean there isn't one that I'm
liking right medical assumptions yeah
what's that problem or assumptions sure
yes oh yeah okay so okay so typically
we're going to force the type 1 air
force ourselves to control the type 1
error rate and subject to that we try to
make the type 2 error rate small making
a type 2 error rate small is the same as
trying to maximize the probability that
we reject for values of theta that are
in the alternative hypothesis so we call
this rejection probability for
alternative values we call it the power
and power being a good thing it's just
the rejection probability and under the
alternative not necessarily no and in
fact the infimum over theta would
usually be alpha the is usually gonna be
some sequence of alternatives you choose
going towards the boundary between the
null and the alternative and the power
is gonna be continuous so yeah so so
what so that's a good very good point
that this is ambiguous in exactly the
same way that the estimation that the
estimation problem was ambiguous for
estimation we said we wanted to minimize
the risk for each value of theta
individually but it we couldn't we had
no hope of doing that simultaneously for
all theta actually the problem is quite
different it's quite different
well it's somewhat different in
hypothesis testing because this is not
in principle it's not in principle
impossible that we could be uniformly
maximizing this power for all values of
theta in the alternative and in fact
under here this is exactly an exam
so so it's still the case that the
infimum is alpha but for each specific
value of theta there's going to be an
obvious choice of test that is going to
make every single be gonna make the
power as large as possible
simultaneously everywhere on the
alternative so power is a function of
theta power is a function of theta it's
not just a number like beta or something
no so that's yeah that's okay that would
be a misconception yeah so people will
often say okay so people often do like a
power analysis they say we want power
eighty percent or something what sample
size do I need well then you have to
make an assumption about what the effect
size is so there's no sample size that's
large enough so the power would always
be eighty percent usually in most so
okay so for example so here X so let's
say X is normally normal theta one and
the null hypothesis is theta is less
than or equal to zero the alternative is
that it's bigger than zero so here I've
plotted pp0 of X and so we're going to
choose some values of x to to make our
rejection region and we just need to
choose our rejection rule so that the
probability is less than alpha so the
obvious one that I think anybody in this
room would go for is we choose sort of
the rightmost values of X here and we're
going to reject when any of those come
up and so we're gonna go far enough to
the right so that the this area is
exactly equal to alpha but of course
this is this is specifically at the
boundary so it could be that theta is
not equal to zero theta could be less so
if theta is much less than zero then the
power might be well 9-0
whereas if theta
is much bigger than zero then the power
could be close to 100% and for every
different value of theta we have
different house so here we can plot this
in one dimension
here here so this is the power and we
wouldn't really usually call it the
power but we can always talk about the
power of the null as well so let's say
this is alpha then what we want to do is
we want to make so there's going to be
some power function we want to make it
as small as possible over here and we
want to make it as big as possible over
here and we want it to be less than or
equal to alpha everywhere on there on
the left and so in fact the test that we
all would have chosen over there would
it is what's called a uniformly most
powerful test it simultaneously makes
the function as big as possible over
here for all power functions that we
could possibly achieve that are less
than alpha everywhere on the left here
small here and we can do that in this
very simple example in more complicated
examples we we generally would not be
able to have a to find a uniformly most
powerful test but you see at least the
situation is not as bad so there's a
whole there's a whole theory on sort of
how to try to choose good tests tests
with with high power which we're not
going to go into so let's get to the
next topic since I have a chance
but yeah they need any questions about
hypothesis usually do we consider the
setting very a lot to draw many samples
from this P theta or is the traditional
industry because it is the one sample
version ah so what
so here I've been sort of implicitly
hiding in the notation what the sample
size is so we could say X might be a
vector of size so what I've drawn here X
is the unit is a single number right
more generally though we could talk
about this problem and if I had an iid
sample from normal theta1 there would be
a test that's very similar to this it
would also be uniformly most powerful
but for example if we had
x1 is normal say 2 1 1 and x2 is normal
say 2 2 2 1
and we want to test the null hypothesis
that theta 1 and theta 2 are both equal
to 0 there actually isn't a uniformly
most powerful test for that so we have
to somehow trade-off between we have
really good power when theta 1 is huge
or we have really good power when theta
2 is huge we kind of can't do both at
the same time so so designing good
designing good tests is sort of a matter
of finding good prioritization figuring
out what are the alternatives that you
care the most about and trying to do
well for the alternatives that you think
are likely to come up without doing too
poorly for the alternate the other
alternatives yes cymatics so we can
measure distances so you sort of try to
understand this the infimum not the
maximum but as long as theta is far away
from theta 0 - so you're saying I know
that theta is at least 1/2 far away from
that a 0 then I take insulin yes you
could do that that would that would be a
way to disambiguate that would be a good
principle for disambiguating is similar
to the minimax
risk so there's something called maximum
testing where you could say let's say
I'm going to take a little tube i7 null
hypothesis going through the parameter
space I'm going to take a little tube
around the null hypothesis and and then
I'm gonna stay outside of that tube I
want to maximize the infimum of the
power so that would be maximum that
that's called the maximum
power and that's a reasonable principle
for trying to find tests it becomes it's
often very difficult to sort of find
that test even in simple problems but
it's a good principle for sort of saying
you know in asymptotic regimes can we
actually distinguish these scenarios at
what rate that sort of thing okay let me
go on to talk about confidence intervals
actually well while I'm on that topic a
nice and clean example would be lets say
that X is some high dimensional normal
as identity covariance potentially high
dimensional and we want to test the null
hypothesis that theta is exactly equal
to the zero vector then well okay I'm
not really gonna have time to do this
but maybe you can imagine that the two
possible tests I could choose so that in
some sense the most obvious one that
would be maximun according to some ball
that we could would take would be to
take and and in fact is is the the best
possible test if we have like an
isotropic prior over theta for any
isotropic prior over theta we want to
reject when this is bigger than the
Alpha quantile of a chi-squared D random
variable this is just a distribution of
that under the noise but if instead beta
is sparse we can do much much better by
reject so the chi-square test rejects
when this is true
but if theta is sparse then we would do
much better to reject when the infinity
norm of X is bigger than turns out to be
something like root 2 log D so under the
null hypothesis the this infinity norm
is likely to be like root 2 log D
whereas this is going to be something
like well we take off the squared this
is going to be something like square
root and okay
I probably shouldn't have done that
because I don't have time to fully do
that out but I'm gonna cut my losses
but if you look up Donahoe and gin is a
very nice analysis of that problem which
each state of one to be smaller in the
second case here since it's sparse like
you're told that beta 1 and beta 0 is a
strict subset of all possibilities I'm
sorry so you have two different tests
here yeah it's the second one using up
you have a fatal one that's smaller in
the second case and in the first case
yes so so the way we would compare these
is we would say let's say that I have
some theta 1 yeah let's say I have a
theta that's not equal to 0 its oriented
in some direction how big does it have
to be for me to get some power and we
can take D to infinity and we can say
how fast does it have to grow if it's a
stays equally sparse in some sense and
it has to grow a lot slower to have
power over here over here yeah I'm sorry
I shouldn't have gone there most
problems don't have um P testing let's
talk about confidence intervals
generally confident sets they don't not
always intervals but I'm just gonna keep
calling them intervals so a 1 minus
alpha confidence interval is an interval
valued or set valued function of X
function of the data which includes
where we usually say it covers the
parameter theta the true parameter theta
with probability at least one minus
alpha so this is saying for all for all
values theta the probability under theta
that the confidence interval contains
theta the backwards in is greater than
or equal to 1 minus alpha and this
should be true for all theta in the
parameter space so that's a confidence
that's a confidence interval or let's
just say a confidence set okay so there
are a lot of people who make a lot of
people claim this is a extremely hard
concept to understand or extremely
confusing I don't think it has to be
extremely confusing it would have been
less confusing if we hadn't chosen the
named confidence interval so the problem
is the confidence interval makes people
think this is like a Bayesian quantity
after you see the data you have some
kind of subjective confidence that the
parameter is in some set that's not what
this is the confidence interval it
an interval valued estimate okay it's an
or I think interval estimation is a nice
name and if we should have called an
interval estimate of the function and it
includes the it includes the parameter
with high probability so so if you just
keep that in mind I don't think there
should be anything confusing the other
thing is I like to write it this way
this sort of subject-verb-object
right this is the thing that's being
covered this is not the thing this is
not the thing that's including itself
into C of X C of X you know instead of
throwing darts at a dartboard we're
shooting paintballs at a dartboard
that's that's all what's happening here
so that's confidence intervals so
confidence intervals so they're they're
very closely related to estimates to
point estimates but for obvious reasons
the goals are sort of similar to point
estimates but actually they're even
claim or closely related to hypothesis
tests
so here the I would say one of the most
important things to know if you want to
make it the most important thing to know
if you want to make a confidence
interval is confidence interval and
hypothesis testing duality
okay so the most general purpose way
to construct a confidence interval is to
do what we call inverting invert a
family of hypothesis tests so what do I
mean by invert what do I mean by a
family if hypothesis test so let's say
we assume I'm gonna say G sub theta 0 is
a test it tests the null hypothesis that
theta equals theta 0 versus the
alternative that theta is not equal to
theta 0 and assume that we have so we
have one for every theta 0 every
possible value of the parameter and
they're all they're all level alpha
tests but I don't know if I define level
alpha but they they control the type 1
error rate at level alpha well then we
can immediately define atleast a
confidence set we wouldn't necessarily
know that it would be an interval but we
can define a confidence set which is
just all the values of theta such that T
theta doesn't reject
okay so it's just all all non rejected
parameter values and I claim that as
long as the tests are all valid this is
always a valid confidence then let's see
why it's a one-liner so then the
probability under theta the C theta
contains theta a C of X contains data it
is exactly equal to the probability
under theta that T theta reject and we
know that sorry let's say it does not
contain theta we know it's exactly equal
to the probability under theta the t
theta reject and that is it's less than
or equal to alpha by definition so QED
and in fact yes this motor in some sense
yeah so usually you you want to you you
want to minimize the inclusion
probability for values of theta that are
not the true parameter so it's actually
sort of equivalent to so if you find it
well let's say if you have a test that
that uniformly maximizes power if you
have a family of tests and they
uniformly maximize power off the
alternative off the no on the
alternative then you're going to get
then you're going to uniformly minimize
the inclusion probability for the and so
you'll get the shortest possible
confidence interval and so sort of
confidence interval so the question of
how to make confidence intervals good we
want them to be short we want them to
exclude most values with high
probability most non true values with
high probability and that's a that's
essentially the same question as how do
we make tests all right
oh that's a good usually we don't talk
about that but maybe we should yes why
would you ever hold your feet to the
fire in formulating a hypothesis test
when you can just create a confidence
interval what do you mean by holding
your feet to the fire like I'm
envisioning I formulate a hypothesis
test before I collect data and then oh I
fail to reject the null crap when I
could have just said no just do a
confidence interval Africa ah I would a
guy politely agree with you it's like
making a confidence interval always
gives you more information than doing a
single test of a point no and it's I
would say it's it's more just that it's
sort of confidence interval summarizes
the results of
a whole lot of tests in a way but this
time you don't have to worry about
multiple testing okay but confidence
intervals summarized are the results of
multiple tests and then we can sort of
deduce that okay we were rejected this
one we rejected this one and yeah it
sort of makes infinity decisions all at
the same time in a way where we control
you know so you you could immediately
deduce the result of that hypothesis
test from let's say I have a cop make a
confidence interval and it excludes
some range that would be a valid way of
testing the hypothesis that the
parameter is in that range it wouldn't
necessarily be an optimal way if I mean
now we're talking about slightly more
complicated problems oh and so before I
take more questions let me just say this
this also goes the opposite direction
right so we can start if you know how to
construct tests you also know how to
make a confidence interval you know to
make confidence interval you also know
how to do testing so okay so similarly
if somebody gives us C of X we can
construct tests tests of H 0 theta
equals theta 0 versus H 1 theta is not
equal to theta 1 by rejecting not only
if theta 0 sorry it's in theta 0 is not
in the confidence interval so it's
almost I mean the confidence interval in
the test they're almost not even
different procedures if you choose so
most of the time in most simple problems
the obvious comp the obvious confidence
interval that we would choose and the
obvious tests that we would do they
coincide so most of the time for most
simple scenarios those simple problems
the natural tests and confidence
intervals have they actually exhibit
this duality that we're talking about so
I can go from a confidence interval and
get tests where you go from tests and
get a confidence interval and in fact
that you know that the tests and the
confidence intervals that we would do do
have this relationship have this
relationship so simple so a simple
example
X is normal data one then you know the
confidence interval would be the obvious
confidence interval would be X minus V
alpha over 2 X plus V alpha over 2 this
is saying the upper alpha over 2
quantile of a normal distribution
aka 1.96 X minus 2x plus 2 and the test
that we would do would be to reject the
null hypothesis say that theta equals 0
if and only if the absolute value of X
is greater than Z alpha over 2 that
would be the obvious two-sided test that
we would do and and so C of X contains 0
if and only if
this is true so and if we were testing
that theta equals any other value it
would have this exact same relationship
so constructing a confidence interval
basically is just equivalent to it's a
nice way of visualizing infinity tests
that you ran confidence intervals have a
lot more benefits to that than that as
well that conceptually you know if I if
I tell you it's better than say if I
report a p-value so okay so if I say
like I reject that the effect size is
equal to zero and the p-value is
extremely extremely extremely tiny that
just means I'm very very very sure that
the effect size is not exactly equal to
zero
if I say the confidence interval is you
know between two and two point one
that's telling you a lot more
information
similarly if I say the p value is 0.7
that just means that the effect might be
zero or it might not
whereas if I told you that the
confidence interval is minus 0.12 plus
0.1 that's telling you that yeah
confidence interval can kind of tell you
the difference between like evidence of
absence and versus absence of evidence
yes four different just you know if you
want a 50-50 chance it's in this very
very small area but if you want to
really be sure that's in this big
interval sure yeah you can you can
report a ninety percent in a 95 percent
confidence and it'll yeah do that I
don't think people often do they just
wouldn't be that different frankly for
you well if we're talking about 90% and
95% they would be all that different
maybe 50% it would be pretty different
from many factors oh yes is there
anything useful be learned from like how
the size of the company grows as you
change the threshold of confidence um uh
I think you that would I don't know how
much that would tell you about your data
I would tell you about the sort of
distributions or the difficulty of the
problem I think or the tales and
probably tell you about the tales of the
problem but you might have worried about
greatness
so okay let me just okay so so for
example you know you'll often read that
scientists didn't find any link between
a and B and if they just say the p-value
is 0.7 I don't know what that means it
might mean that that they looked really
hard they had extremely high quality
evidence and it's very clear that
there's no major link between a and B or
it could mean that they had really poor
quality evidence maybe the data was very
hard to obtain and so it just turned out
that there's no way to know whether a is
linked there's the link between a and B
the confidence interval would give us
the difference between those right if we
say that the parameter is between 0.01
and let's say minus 0.01 and 0.02 that's
telling me something a very different
thing than if I say it's between minus 8
and 30 I think you had your hand at
first yeah so I think of finding
computing a confidence interval as being
a prevent to choose pre specifying an
infinite number of hypotheses and then
running the experiment and then
selecting one of those hypotheses to
publish afterwards
so should we would be worried about
maybe in in other words should we be
worried about multiple hypothesis
testing here since I just said we're
doing an uncountably infinite number of
hypotheses testing so in fact no you
shouldn't and the reason is because only
one of those hypotheses is true and so
we don't actually we actually only have
one chance to reject a true null
hypothesis only one of the theta values
is actually true so even though we do
infinite number of tests only one of
them do we actually have a chance to
make a type 1 error
yes
sherbet and in either of these cases the
p-value would be I don't know if it's
exactly the point seven but but right
either
okay so let's let's make this more
symmetric let's make this - ten thirty
and make this three great you know
either if this is the if this is the
confidence interval or this is the
confidence interval the p-value would
actually be the same it's the standard
error is is much wider here right so
this this would be like X's no this
would be something like X is normal
theta 500 variance 500 and this would be
like X's normal data you know variance
is something very small so it's about
the variance so it's just saying we're
not sure whether we're not sure whether
theta is zero it doesn't tell you it
could be the case that we're really sure
theta is close to zero or it could be
the case we just have no idea what these
at all and confidence intervals
distinguish yes you mentioned that
confidence is the most things actually
be sets and in that example it's
actually
that's in devil-like two people already
usually won't go to post it to being um
it's not usually not necessary so it
usually either is an interval or compact
you know region of space that would be
very rare if you had that and you were
troubled by it you might just take the
smallest interval that includes them but
probably you would start by asking
yourself why is this happening because
it would be surprising I guess if the
most uh no I don't think no I don't
think we could say that that has more to
do it because we could always just sort
of scramble the ordering of the
parameter values and then we would
destroy all those properties but we'd
still have most powerful tests but okay
let me because I only have 15 minutes
and I really like to tell you about
maximum likelihood it'll be a miracle
that
so maximum likelihood so maximum
likelihood is a great general-purpose
way if you go into a statistics
department and you say that you came up
with an estimator for some model and you
did some kind of complicated Rube
Goldberg type machine to get it or even
if you didn't you did something simple
you might expect to be asked by somebody
why didn't you use the maximum
likelihood estimator did you try that
with something wrong with it and the
reason is because it's just a very sort
of general purpose a general purpose way
of estimating a parameter that works
very well in a certain tame a synthetic
regime it at the very least and they
also work well other times as well okay
so so the general way is exactly we
choose some value of theta that make the
that makes the probability of the data
as likely as possible so this is not the
same as taking like a posterior mode
this is not the value of theta that's
most likely in light of seeing X to do
that we would need to be beige ins this
is a frequentist thing we're saying
choose the value of theta for which we
would be least surprised to see data X
so there's no a priori there's no a
priori sort of epistemological grounding
for this for this choice it just happens
to work well so max so first of all
there need not be any Maximizer here
depending on the properties of P theta
the properties of capital theta there
need not be any Maximizer if there
exists one it may not be unique it may
even be a bad estimator but what what
we'll see in a moment is that as the
sample size gets very large the it will
become more likely that the Maximizer is
unique and that you know it has very
nice properties that are easy to
describe
is this well-defined at peak beta isn't
a density but some weird mixture of
different types of distributions that's
a very good question yes I think it
would be actually it would be because
there's only one X that we see so it
could be that that that P theta is like
a mix of discrete atoms and you know it
wouldn't even be that weird it is a mix
of discrete atoms and like some
continuous Mass smeared over whatever
but we're gonna the X that we get is
going to be either in the zero
dimensional part at the sample space or
the 1 dimensional part of the 2
dimensional part and so so so okay it
has nice properties for large sample
sizes
so let's assume that X 1 up to X n now
our iid from some common distribution P
theta of X and so now the likelihood so
here I was writing the likelihood as P
theta of X but now the likelihood slight
abuse of notation but now the likelihood
is the product I equals 1 up to N
of P theta of capital X I okay and so
this is what we're going to be
maximizing so theta hat let's call it
theta hat n it's going to be in the Arg
max of top of the product P theta X I
which actually this becomes nicer to
deal with if we write it as the Arg max
of the sum of L theta X i where L of
theta X is the log P theta
so a very nice thing about rewriting
this into rights of this this is a
monotonic transform we've just taken the
log of the whole thing so it's the same
Arg max but the nice thing about what
we've done now is now we have a sum of
iid things so we can start bringing to
bear things like the likelihood the law
of large numbers of going moving to the
log log scale is going to give us some
of my ID things and we know a lot about
how sums of iid things behave in
particular we know the law of large
numbers which is that 1 over N times the
sum of X I is going to converge to the
expectation of X I and 1 over square
root n this is in the central limit
theorem as well 1 over square root n if
I take the X I and I subtract off the
mean and now I normalize it more gently
1 over root n instead of 1 over n then
this actually is going to converge to
normal zero variance X I there are you
know there are conditions under which
this is the case but we're not going to
worry about them right now okay so let's
say X has medium mean and variance this
is true
so right so that's the the law of large
numbers in the CLT we'll be able to
apply those so so the idea is that we're
going to tailor expand around so so now
let's let's say because I want to use a
function theta I want to use theta is
the argument to a function let's say
theta zero is the true value so I want a
Taylor expand around the true value
we're jumping to call theta zero now so
what do I get I get that the sum of L
theta oh and the other thing is that
I've written it this way now with theta
being the first argument because now
instead of so here we're usually
thinking of this as a function of X and
theta changes what function of X it is
now we should really think of this as a
function of theta because we're
maximizing over theta here so each of
these terms is a random function of
theta where X I tells me which function
of theta I get right so now we're sort
of switching the way we think of it this
is a random function of theta I sum up
and random functions of theta and I
maximize it we want to know how these
behave okay so the sum is you know sum
of L theta 0 X I plus theta minus theta
0 times the sum of L prime theta 0 X I
plus theta minus theta 0 squared over 2
times the sum L double prime theta 0
exei plus higher order terms so what we
see is we're going to Taylor expand this
around the true value of theta theta
zero and what we end up with is we get a
quadratic in theta whose coefficients
are these sums so if theta zero is fixed
here so the coefficients are we have
random coefficients for quadratic
function and so we're approximately
getting a random quadratic function and
that's going to be easy to sort of
maximize and talk about the properties
of the Maximizer in terms of what these
coefficients are plus the higher order
terms that we're not going to justify
why we can ignore them but we can under
appropriate conditions so
furthermore these coefficients we know a
lot about what they're going to look
like for large n because their sums of
simple iid things so the next thing we
want to know is what are the first what
are the first couple moments of L Prime
and L double Prime this is going to
become very important right so these
random coefficients are going to
determine what the maximum is so so the
way that we are going to talk about
those moments is we're going to
differentiate repeatedly differentiate
the identity integral P theta of X DX
equals 1 okay so if we do it once let's
say we can pull the derivative inside of
the integral that again is the step we
would technically need to justify but
we're not going to justify it right now
so I can rewrite P theta of X is e to
the a la l theta of X DX and if I
differentiate this side I just get zero
so I differentiate this I get L prime of
theta e to the Alpha Theta F X Y x
equals zero but remember this is P theta
of X this is the probability density and
so this is saying that the expectation
of the derivative of the log likelihood
is zero as long as this theta the truth
eita
and the theta at which I'm taking the
derivative are the same the expectation
is equal to zero so that worked very
well so let's differentiate again what
happens if we differentiate one more
time
that differentiate again and I'm going
to get the D theta
in here D D theta of L prime theta X e
to the L theta X DX and again
differentiate zero and I get zero so now
I have I have a product rule so I have
two terms one of which is L l double
prime times e to the L and the other one
is L prime squared times e to the L so
this is L double prime plus L prime
squared times P theta of X DX equals
zero and so now I can rewrite this as
minus minus the expectation of the
second derivative equals the expectation
of the first derivative
squared right the expectation of the
first derivative squared because the
first derivative has zero mean this is
the same as the variance
okay so this variance is called the the
Fisher information and we also can write
it as I of theta so this is called the
Fisher information it's a very important
quantity in statistics and we'll we're
about to see one of
one of its important properties okay so
we're almost so we're ready to finally
compute the distribution of the maximum
likelihood estimator so here so we're
going to go back to the Taylor expansion
and we're going to differentiate the
Taylor expansion to try to characterize
what's the Maximizer of this approximate
quadratic function so we'll say zero is
the derivative with respect to theta of
this sum this is the thing that we're
trying to maximize and if I evaluate it
at theta equals theta hat n then it
should be zero right
and so then what happens when we
differentiate the right hand side over
here well this this doesn't depend on
theta only theta 0 so this goes away so
we get this sum sum of L Prime at theta
0 X I plus theta minus theta 0 times the
sum of L double prime theta 0 X I and
we're plugging in at theta n hat so it's
equal to theta n hat so I have 0 is
approximately equal to this sum so now
all I have to do is rearrange and I get
theta n hat minus theta 0 this is the
error is approximately equal to L Prime
some of the L Prime's
divided by let's put the minus sign down
here minus the sign of the L double
Prime's now this looks like we're in
very good shape we're gonna be able to
apply things like central limit theorem
and and the the law of large number is
it's just a question of what's the right
normalization so the first thing we
could try is we could do 1 over n up
here and 1 over n down here then we know
this is going to converge in probability
to its expectation 0 and this is going
to converge in probability to its
expectation which is I of theta ok so
that looks like good news so this is
saying that this error is going to 0
so they actually give us some cheer but
it would be nice if we could make them
more if we could make a more precise
statement than that so instead let's
inflate this error
by square root n and then it'll have a
limiting distribution so we put a square
root n up there and now this one
converges to a normal zero and now this
is also I theta zero so this is I
because that's the expectation of minus
L double prime this is I because that's
the variance of L of L Prime and so what
we then get is that this whole thing is
converging to normal zero I theta
inverse and if we rearrange things a bit
then we can get maybe a more familiar
looking but slightly less formal more
informal statement that theta n had is
approximately normal theta zero one over
N times the inverse Fisher information
so that is the asymptotic distribution
of the MLE
just the last couple points the to
justify this Taylor expansion but we do
need not only a couple regularity
conditions but we also need to justify
sort of our initial assumption that
theta n hat ought to be close to theta 0
in the first place right so it's paused
so it doesn't matter what the dish what
the function looks like locally near
theta 0 if there's some if this my
parameter space is so huge that there's
always some other faraway value where
something wild is going on right so we
need regularity near theta 0 and then we
need some kind of global argument to get
us going to say that that actually data
and had is is getting close to theta 0
it is converging to a neighborhood of
theta 0 and as long as that's true then
we get this distribution V mle looks
like I'm a couple minutes over time but
anybody has any
burning questions or you can just come
up after all right thank you very much
[Applause]
no only to save my hand know that yeah
exactly the same proof goes through with
that if I want to approach mater eh eh
you know the puppy which has some noise
what has a probability with some reason
here we're assuming that I know you
always entity called you what do you
feel hovers over the lead have some
voices series uh okay I'm not trying it
so the data sort of always have noise
maybe I'm misunderstanding the question
like the data are random they sort of
are annoyed yeah but I mean cranky so I
have some noise both on the model
Oh a specification is model okay maybe
model myth specification are you saying
we don't observe X I directly we observe
X I plus some yeah we observe X I plus
epsilon I or something like that yes I
think you could if you could add that to
the model and you would just have a
different model for how the data arises
from theta and then you could still
carry out this program now if you didn't
realize that somebody were noisy up the
data and so you use the model where you
actually get it directly observe X i but
in fact you you're unbeknownst to you
you're observing noisy versions of X I
then I think this other gentleman's
comment would be accurate you'd be
dealing as model miss miss vacation
maybe we can discuss offline if I'm not
answering the question
okay oh thanks very much oh okay you can
come after all right thanks very much